what kind of work do you do brother
you flip houses okay somebody blew that
that guy rents for sure
yeah you [ __ ] bozo get your [ __ ]
together all right get a little get a
little working capital you get a couple
of sleeve tattoos too
FHA loan or something let's go you do
you do the construction
oh really
damn this kid's all right tell you that
right now
all right did you go to school did you
go to college
I'm rich [ __ ] what are you talking
about
you live do you own your own home or do
you rent
you own nice two acres two acres and a
barn you got horses in there
pigs just took a turn okay
now
he rescues pot belly pigs oh that's so
sweet though from where
from my house probably
Run for Your Land
line evil bastards going
I got the syrup in my hand
fat ass back here that's so sweet that's
so awesome
yeah I can imagine
I can imagine all right let's get into
it this guy's feeding himself and do
good of a picture okay I'm getting
turned on right now I'll tell you that
right now his question is are you
garbage if you had to leave your mom's
wedding after the ceremony because your
house arrest officer wouldn't let you go
to the reception
foreign
[Laughter]
whoa what'd you do
it
I think it was a little more than one
yeah I was feeling pigs got sucker
how much weed are we talking are we
talking about weight
you still got any connection I think
that's the one thing he's being very
humble about
he was a couple of keys of Bam Bam
kids movies
[Music]
[Applause]
Kansas City all right where's Joshua P
at right here what's up there he is how
you doing first day of school right
there hello right here he's got a
backpack on and off right here Mr Ryan
and Mr Foley my mom made my lunch who
are you here with Buddy
your wife and I saw you guys been
married
five years nice not enough for that
that's great
right where was the reception Church
okay wait a minute
this sounds like a cult or something
but you guys you had a party at the
church yeah like downstairs or whatever
yeah
not in the actual
through the Tabernacle
hey there's wine back here
some kind of weird Rich cracker let's go
back I shouldn't have said that about
the Eucharist I know it I told me I hope
we hit a bunch of turbulence on the way
back you're gonna be [ __ ] your pants
all right what's your credit score
looking like
he just wanted to say 69.
I think you just checked on your phone
right before the show these [ __ ]
ain't getting me I'll tell you that
right there
and you own your place or you're ready
we just sold it you just sold this guy
bought it
okay what do you guys all [ __ ] real
estate here Jesus Christ
you just sold your house so where are
you living now
[Music]
why Virginia if you don't mind me asking
uh living by the ocean
is there an ocean in Virginia
I don't know who's Dumber
yeah there's an ocean I think oh yeah
Virginia Beach stop okay nice well
that's congratulations that's all with
you right what are you gonna do when you
get there
shaving alpacas and llamas
where are we dude
I feel like we traveled back to the
1800s
by the way I'll tell you now I haven't
seen a city anywhere that we have been
Kansas is right over there
I haven't seen we didn't see anything
but chosen hospitals and Sheridan hotels
and that just put the cherry on top lava
boy I'll tell you that right now
this one is insane
this whole night I mean
okay
um
who's your Joshua right okay
this is insane are you garbage if you
leave the plastic wrapper on the hotel
water cup when you drink from it
they reuse that dude
that's crazy you really thought you were
cheating the system there huh foreign
what's going on there
to the hotel room I mean I understand
but why are you doing that
he's faster
alpacas the shame he can't be tied down
with [ __ ] plastic wrappers who you
[ __ ] garyvee what are you talking
about
who uses those cups anyway
what were you drinking out of those cups
what are you worried about plastic you'd
be better off eating the glass what are
you nuts
that's crazy that's crazy do you do that
also too wife no you gotta make him stop
doing that
yeah that's you're you're an insane
person I don't know that's garbage but
you are crazy
that's quite a while when you shave the
alpacas you ever put like lines or
anything in them
this kid's all right all right cool
that was awesome
[Applause]